so on the tour we've got three bands say
hey to the new group hello
we're the Bellas formerly a Barden
University and currently of life you
guys are seeing other people's songs
right oh my god um guys stop they just
don't like sharing the spotlight so
they're trying to intimidate us thinkin
what I'm thinkin what a second reef off
yes yes what is it refer a riff off is a
little game that we like to play we
start with a beat oh yeah oh go ladies
[Music]
[Music]
with my Bella
[Music]
is that feedback so it's singing guys
still need that level check for vocals
Oh baby we're just getting started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they just swallowed by themselves by
using these measurements we just had we
won guys we should go
we won fellas are doing what they do
best quitting here's the problem John
the Bellas are not as good as the other
bands that is a startling insight
[Music]
alright ladies were going to show them
that we are not a joke
let's talk of innocence try to have some
dignity
we don't do anything we have dignity
okay
what a beautiful every one of them going
nowhere so what do you want to sing
tonight I brought this just again we
didn't invite you guys to sing we
invited you to watch excuse me I just
thought you guys are so busy with your
awesome jobs and amazing lives I am
actually you're so bright and shiny
still pretty they look like they was all
breastfed rigueur the USO cuts on this
performance to support the troops in
Europe one last show together who is
with me
oh yeah
[Music]
welcome to Spain fellas so this is the
first base will we be going to second
base with you guys that's a no for me so
on the tour we've got three bands you
guys are seeing other people's songs
right like a cover band they're trying
to intimidate us let's just do it to a
reef off
we like to keep it oral
is it where that everybody is that the
one thing that we do then then we are at
that thing
all right ladies pick up your test we're
going to show them that we are not a
joke my record label wants to sign one
of the bands but we don't want the bonus
we want you what I did not see this
coming
their family we support each other we
like sisters Aubrey
he is Aubry isn't it I can't I'm part of
a group Becca it's a big opportunity for
you
[Music]
bye-bye Bela's it really does feel like
goodbye John Becca what are you doing
don't yeah if you cry I'm gonna cry
don't make that face I'm not doing it
don't make a face this is my regular
face
[Music]
you